Dayton police in the FBI have a long
history of working together side by side
in this community including very very
important Joint Terrorism Task Force
assignments that they Denise officers
have as well as our safe streets task
force so working together is nothing new
for us an FBI agent showed up in the
early morning hours in the Oregon
district after this horrific mass attack
so our investigation with dayton police
is ongoing we have not made any final
investigative conclusions into the
motive of the shooter or if he was
assisted by any other people in this
attack however we have uncovered
evidence throughout the course of our
investigation that the shooter was
exploring violent ideologies and based
upon this evidence we're initiating an
FBI investigation side by side with the
Dayton police homicide investigation
to make sure we get to the bottom and we
explore everything and we got try to
understand the best we can why this
horrific attack happened so as we
continue to conduct this investigation
we are striving to do three things
what to figure out three things what if
any ideology influenced the attacker to
conduct this attack who if anyone helped
him or had any advance of knowledge of
his intentions to conduct this attack
and why he committed this specific act
of violence one piece of evidence does
not necessarily constitute a motive
hence the need for a thorough methodical
investigation the case is ongoing so we
cannot provide any detailed information
into our investigative activities at
this time this absolutely critical that
we do this investigation the right way
this community and our country deserves
an answer as to why this happened so we
asked anybody with additional
information regarding this investigation
to provide that information to the FBI
tip line it's a tip line that's
available 24/7 for somebody to give
information that tip line is 1-800
if you call there and ask to give
information about the data Dayton
shooting somebody will take that
information and provide at both of the
Dayton Police Department in to the FBI
there is another outlet in which people
can provide any type of digital evidence
that they may have collected whether on
that
or any social media evidence that they
may feel is relevant to why this attack
happened and that can be provided at WWF
bi govt govt backslash dayton shooting i
also want to thank all the organizations
in this community that have stepped up
to help the grieving process and the
healing process begins here in dayton
I'll take a couple questions so I'm not
going to get into specifics as what
we've found because we're so early in
this investigation there is so much more
material to go through and evidence to
obtain in this investigation but we have
found very specific violent ideologies
that the shooter
we know followed and was interested in
so that has given us enough information
to open up an FBI investigation to make
sure we have every single tool every
investigative capability to figure out
why this happened and to try to make
sure it doesn't happen again
so anybody that wants to to do violence
that is part of what has to be shown to
investigate a federal investigation of
this type and so yeah so we have found
very specific one thing I'll point out
that we have not found any indication
that it's a racial motivation that is
not them any we have not found that
anything that indicates that it's a
racial motivation at this time I'm not
you know again we have a lot to go
through so but different violent
ideologies will cause in this
investigation to be initiated and we
have found evidence of a violent
ideology but I'm not gonna I'm not going
to get I'm not getting into the get into
the specifics we did not discover it off
his computer we're still going through
lots of digital evidence but I'm not
going to tell you exactly where we found
this because we still have a lot more to
go through
we don't we do not have that information
for some we don't know so what we what
we saw on this is this individual the
shooter the attacker in this case very
specifically seeking out information
that promotes violence we are going back
as far as we need to find try to find
out why he did this and also if anybody
else knew about this or was involved
with this we don't know it at this time
I don't have that information at this
time I'm not going to get any more
specifics about what we do or what we do
not know we have not seen any evidence
that the events in El Paso influenced
him at this point again we have lots of
evidence to go through no we have no
evidence that the shooter was on the
FBI's radar prior to this event thank
you thank you special agent next I'm
gonna invite assistant chief Matt Carper
to the podium to discuss the President
of the United States this visit tomorrow
Thank You mayor I know there's been a
lot of interest in in a potential visit
from the the president into the Miami
Valley area tomorrow we don't have the
specifics yet as soon as we can get more
additional information as it unfolds
we'll release what we're able to release
to the public I know any closures or
inconveniences interruptions would be
minimal so we do understand that so
we'll share more information as it
becomes available and as we're able to
that's all I'm able to offer
I'm sorry I'll be able to give you more
information as as the details are
confirmed I'm not aware of any of any
organized protests tomorrow with with
any presidential visit or motorcade
going back decades that is the case we
are always ready for any kind of
dignitary protection assignment like I
said going back decades we've provided
those and and sometimes multiple
occasions per year so yes that is
correct we are ready thank you I didn't
say that no I said we don't have not
developed any evidence at this point
that says that he's influenced by El
Paso we still have a lot of evidence to
go through so I'm not gonna say anything
else about that
I know I think we've discussed
everything we're gonna discuss about the
investigation so are there any other
questions no we have not I don't know
that that's clear I mean we just we
don't have any specific information to
really understand that this time we just
know what happened you know actually
I've been a little too busy to read the
gun first proposal so until I have a
chance to the region evaluate it I
really can't comment well you were you
were all there
so I I don't need to I don't want to
keep on going but you know I don't know
what you're really asking it frankly
actually oh yeah yeah I will welcome in
in the official capacity as mayor since
he is in the office of the president
we're we're not gonna getting the
evidence that was seized in that search
for me that's all part of the
investigation and we haven't a chance to
even evaluate someone at this point so
we're done talking about the
investigation so I think we're done with
questions today we appreciate and I'll
see some of you a national night out
thank you